[Music]
do you know why the phoenix sits on the
right hand of the emperor
she is his guardian
his protector i think people are going
to be surprised because this movie
is obviously the legend of mulan you
guys definitely touch on stuff from the
animation but it's its own
new and amazing things so what what was
it about to make sure this movie was
original from
the animation what did you kind of like
set as sort of like the reasoning behind
that like this is what we want to do
well we went back to the original ballad
it was written in the 7th century
and tried to honor the dna of that the
legacy of that
but also bring iconic elements from the
beloved animation
to the live action and and create
something that
audiences a way for audiences to
experience this
this story again in a completely new way
and then yifei you've grown up with this
legend from probably as long as you can
remember
but what would you say is the most the
best addition to this virgin that you
think
audiences maybe you know globally are
going to be excited about or american
audiences are going to be like wow i
just didn't know or see this before
i think it's the true every because
movie
language is magic it has so
many possibilities and the best thing i
think
actors or artists can focus on is to
bring
the true self out as mulan did
and and people will feel
you know whatever they wanted to feel
yeah
excellent um again this movie is uh
pg-13 is the very first
disney live action that is pg-13 so it's
obviously designed for
young young people you know teenagers
tweens
what do you think is going to be
specific that you want those people
to take from the story i'll ask both of
you but i'll start with you
i think never give up your dream never
give up
finding how strong you
are and just be so happy
with so satisfied with yourself and so
you'll be able to be a better person
to be more
to knowing what love is to in order to
you know no matter family or your lover
or more you know
in a more depth way yeah excellent and
what about you what do you want
young folks to take from the story yeah
for me uh
the the most important thing about
this version of the character is that
she recognizes that she's only going to
be
truly powerful and she is extremely
powerful
but only when she commits to who she
really is where she loses the disguise
of being a young man
and she goes to war as a woman
and and her power and that
in that moment is infinite yeah i don't
want to give anything away but that was
one of those moments to have me like
tearing up
like i'm telling y'all you just made me
like have all the feels on this movie
um but on like the rousing side too this
is no joke this is a
in your face like like a real i think
like an action movie and people are
going to be surprised about that so
talk about for you directing some of the
greatest fight choreographers with donny
jet and yufe and then talk about you
i mean you got to take it to every
single one of them so i'll start with
you and then you talk about like taking
it to these boys
um yeah nothing but a thrill and a
privilege for me to be working with
those actors
to have donnie yen on set for the first
time with a sword he does a little sword
display
and he moves that sword so fast i could
not even
see the sword i had to shoot the
sequence again
in slow motion just to see what the man
was doing
i mean he is phenomenal and and
what a joy to shoot
to shoot action
from a very joyous female point of view
and it's it's explosive and it's
thrilling and it's also
really beautiful and the hair always
looks great
i agree with that what about you yeah
i think of course you you already see
jed and donnie they their skill is
donnie when he's resting he's like
chatting and now have fun
and then i said donny on set and then
you know all of a sudden
he's like that but all the boys i have
to say
they train so hard they have six packs
they don't they eat but they most time
protein shakes
good for them you know and
you know just their spirits always
encourages me
when they find out who you are they will
show you no mercy
[Music]
i think people are going to be surprised
at how good the fighting is in this
movie
and the different styles in it so can
you maybe for like
the people that don't know break down
the type of fighting in this film
because it's
very specific oh okay uh
i think this
action you know in the mulan the action
team the action choreographer director
they did a wonderful job and before
shooting they already did
animated so all the movements i think a
lot of new angle to see new movement
for mulan you know not only mulan danny
you know everybody
a lot of fight better just watch
yourself
i also have a fighter
but a little bit just more talk
more time but good talking i mean
there's a the emperor is a very
important part in this
donnie i guess got to do more of the
fighting so i
i definitely get it um when you got the
script did you notice
any of the like very specific like
chinese culture touches that you were
like
really happy to see in the story
well i think all chinese people grew up
they know mulan already automatically
because unless they are in blood you
know uh the girl you know
fighting you know uh but always
you make mulan you you consider you
have a new idea in it because everybody
do the story why i
watch again you know that's the
difficult part
but i'm so glad the writer and director
they use the new angle 21st century
for the young audience special girl how
to be their hero
you know mulan so i'm so great
so glad to make it because
walking on the side that's my after 40
years making my way you know the first
group director photographer everybody is
woman
the mean idea yes i love that
yeah no i say can i take a picture and
the king sit there on the director
photographer make up everybody great
he's a woman i love it i love that me
because it's
special today in the women's day i
always yeah i always
respect women because i grew up as a
single mother
and my when i was two years old my
daddy passed away so i reset by my mom
alone so i always respect
women in my life yeah and i love that
we're recording this on international
women's day you're right this is like
the perfect day to do this
particular movie absolutely um so i will
apologize before she got cast as mulan i
did not know a lot about ife
but after she got cast i went back and
looked at it oh my gosh this girl is
amazing and sends
so many incredible movies but tell
american audiences if they were going to
go look at you know her filmography you
got to go check this one out you got to
see her in this what she what should
they go see
yeah when i was uh first time to see her
she's only 17 14
14 14. she's a very young girl i want to
do a movie
you know i say wow my first look i know
this
the actress in the famous in the future
yeah
then she's a very special
she's very quiet not easy a lot of
people to talk and you know but she
worked very hard
very hard and i remember 12 years ago
maybe 13 years ago i work with her
with jackie chan you know together we
have one movie together
so she did a wonderful job she always
wanted to learn
learn learn uh yeah she's
very special you know a lot of actresses
similar one
she's very special but during this movie
also she said i'm so afraid i said what
are you afraid he said
how can i save you the most
powerful fighter i save you you know i
say
you're not you're not ife you're mulan
you know
that's whole world girl respect
you need to do your job forget your name
you're just mulan
well she did do that and she's
definitely milan and yeah she's
great she saved you and donnie which is
like the best yeah
that's why she's nervous i said if
yourself
you know you don't need to worry there's
a mulan never worry
what is your name soldier paging
commander son of hojo
[Music]
we're going to make men out of every
single one of you
[Music]
i just want to know any time on set do
y'all ever like try to outdo each
other like you know do a little behind
the scenes uh not in this one
in i mean our very first encounter many
years ago
the first two movie i mean like any type
of moment
with two great artists when they have
that moment they just
go like two singers they outdo each
other they're not dancers or
boxers right but this one uh to be
honest we
we never had a scene together in this
movie i'm sorry to spoil the
the plot but uh but it was so pleasant
to
be in the same thing with him i think
it's kind of our
friendships and our fate
to be able to it's very difficult to be
in the same film
all the time and we've been this is our
fourth time so
that's really great yeah i know you
spent a lot of your time obviously with
yfay being the commander
um i have to say i'm sorry to say before
she was cast mulan i didn't know much
about her but when she got cast i went
and looked at her filmography girl
has been killing it since she was a
teenager um
she's done a lot of stuff yeah i mean
what would you say to folks that maybe
like didn't know about her
maybe what films they should maybe check
out or what they should know about yfay
you know the actress playing mulan
she's a very hard worker very
have a tremendous background in dance
i think it's the work ethic she
represents because i think it's really
important to
especially the this show business is
very competitive
you got to bring it on i mean you got to
have the whole package
not just talent there's a lot of talent
to people in the world
but if you don't work hard you're not
going to go anywhere
so she got both best of
both works she talented and she worked
hard and
when they cast her and i thought to
myself i said
this team made the right choice she's
beautiful
she's uh elegant
she work hard and she has a strong
foundation of this type of films
as well because it's really important i
mean she didn't start start off from
scratch
and by working with her on the set in
new zealand and she's very dedicated as
well
i mean the way she uh tackled the
the her lines and her poise and
a lot let alone all the training
sessions she went through
so i'm very very happy for her
i'm hua mulan i will bring honor to us
[Music]
all